si vous êtes en train de penser à
quitter votre maison pour vous en allez
en résidence de retraite ou encore que
vous magasinez une place pour vos
parents ceci va beaucoup vous intéresser
parce que ça pourrait vous coûter pas
mal plus cher que vous pensez qu'on
facture
la présentation l'appui des glycémies
les gouttes pour les yeux
les crèmes pour le corps ou des choses
comme ça il ya de la grogne dans ces soi
disant tout inclus avec beaucoup d'extra
ce sur quoi on fait comme c'est sympa
qu'un excès des entourloupettes pas et
me soucier un peu d'argent ciel peu
dangereux
bon ça ça porte bonheur un arrêté de
charrier que nous exploiter comme ça
c'est clair
est-ce que la sécurité promise dans le
discours de vente est toujours au
rendez-vous et cameron sont les regarde
pas ça au sérieux et on reste
inacceptable
ses propriétaires de résidences privées
disent qu'ils ont besoin des aides
qu'ils veulent plus d'argent public mais
il faut qu'on me de profits au fait à un
moment donné au fait que les résidences
ouvrent leurs livres parce que on peut
pas le beurre et l'argent du beurre
si marie maude denis bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
une retraite sans tracas finie la
pelouse l'entretien de la maison
le fardeau des repas la vie l hôtel au
quotidien c'est leur ai vendu dans les
publicités de résidences privées pour
aînés sur la sécurité se situait tomasi
de tomber malade
ddp à la maison je tombe c'est même un
portable se blesser au québec il y à
plus de 1700 résidences privées pour
aînés des établissements à but lucratif
qu'on appelle couramment des rpa la
moitié des rpa au pays est au québec
le modèle québécois et il a du succès
mammuth a moins besoin de moins faire la
cuisine et tout venant d'avoir à cet
accident la montée en gamme sont
vendeurs forman et randy trop loin plus
de cent trente et un mille retraités en
fait le choix d'y vivre
c'est presque une personne sur scène
parmi la population de 75 ans et plus
mais leur confort a un prix
tout est pensé pour plaire aux retraités
dynamiques selon coiffure pharmacie
piscine salon qui table de billard tout
sous un même toit
c'est une vie confortable c'est on
accommode les gens avec un certain
confort mais on veut surtout créer une
atmosphère des carottes de camaraderie
jean françois gilbert conseil des
propriétaires de rpa dans leurs projets
d'expansion
il ya de la compétition oui il ya
plusieurs en fait ce qu'on remarque dans
le marché c'est que la plupart des gros
développeurs recherchent le même genre
de terrain le même genre de site parce
que les sites localisés près des
services ou est-ce que c'est sécuritaire
de marcher sur les trottoirs ce sont des
sites préférés préféré des développeurs
depuis 2010 le nombre de résidences pour
annie explose la publicité vise à
attirer entre autres les baby boomers
actifs ils sont nombreux les premiers
auront 75 ans cette année donc une
grosse vague qui s'en vient
il ya plusieurs personnes qui veulent
accommoder cette clientèle là où
profiter de cette manne voit en fait
c'est je pense pas que le mot profiter
et juste je crois que pour les
promoteurs c'est plus de 2 de pouvoir
offrir à cette clientèle là
mode d'habitation qui est attractif pour
eux
[Musique]
il n'aime pas le thé en profiter mais
c'est en construise autant ce doit être
rentable soixante dix nouvelles rpa
seront construites d'ici deux ans au
québec des investissements de 3
milliards de dollars les bruits vont
maintenir la cadence
les propriétaires projet de construire
entre 2000 et 4000 appartement par année
pendant 25 ans une explosion qui découle
de la faillite des soins à domicile
selon l'ancien ministre de la santé
réjean hébert on ne peut pas été capable
d'assurer les personnes âgées qu'un code
perte d'autonomie
il y aurait des services qui seraient
disponibles dans leur maison c'est tout
inclus déroule le tapis rouge en
promettant la sécurité et l'assurance de
soins lorsque vous en aurez besoin
mais ses soins sur des prix fort quand
il y en a tous ne sont pas capables de
se les payer les intérêts des
investisseurs peuvent entrer en conflit
avec ceux des résidents on a fait le
choix au québec d'utiliser la solution
institutionnelle que son lycée à celle
des et de façon intermédiaire les
résidences de personnes âgées qui sont
le chemin la voie royale vers le ch à 7
[Musique]
cinq grands développeurs domine ce
marché ils ont des établissements au
québec mais aussi au canada et aux états
unis
au québec elle se divise le territoire
des grands centres urbains alors que
d'autres plus petits groupes sont
présents en région
dans une ère pea le loyer moyen est de
1844 dollars par mois mais il peut
grimper jusqu'à 3 mai 500 $ sans
services personnalisés les revenus de
retraite sont au rendez vous pour les
gens qui sont intéressés de vivre dans
ce type d'habitation là quand on parle
des bébé-boumeurs aussi on parle de ceux
qui sont arrivés dans le marché du
travail avec l'arrivée de là en fait la
mise en place de la révolution
tranquille au début des années 60 donc
plusieurs d'entre eux ont eu une
carrière entre guillemets dans la
fonction publique ce qui fait en sorte
qu'ils ont
quand même une retraite des rentes
intéressante à bonjour violon voix se
fait à visiter l'appartement
mais le tigre ou anciens administrateurs
dans la fonction publique habite la
résidence les appartements de bordeaux à
québec un complexe luxueux de chaque
fois le camp salon avec la fenêtre qui
donne sur le jardin
il paie 3850 dollar par mois incluant
deux repas par jour pour son épouse et
lui ce jeune homme de 92 ans mène une
bataille contre le groupe château et
pour des hausses de loyer qu'ils
considèrent abusive gp11 1 ou 2 1 le
bien pris deux points 9 passes
conservait pas qu'on pouvait des
gauchers dans une telle confrontation
tous ne sont pas égaux
la protectrice du citoyen l'avait
souligné dans son rapport de 2016
portant sur l'ensemble des résidences
privées pour aînés
le locataire qui se plaint vise une
entreprise ou un individu dont il dépend
chaque jour pour des soins qui lui sont
indispensables
en pareil contexte des locataires
craignent d'être la cible de
représailles
ce qui m'a animé sileny l'iniquité qui
avait dans la négociation des beaux
comme jose il la madone les madame les
monsieur qui ne va pas l'expérience pour
les capacités physiques où vous irez
connaissances expériences pour les
capable de débattre leur corps à une
fois que j'ai appris qu'on pouvait les
glaciers que j'ai recherché 1.4 1.5 1.6
alors que alors que opm 2.9 paie tous
ceux qui tuent ceux qui savaient pas qui
est à la fois les forces c'est ça que je
trouve ça pas correct en 2018 avec d
autres résidents marc petit groupe
conteste devant le tribunal
administratif du logement chat web et
les locataires sont en finalement en
coulisses pour une augmentation de 1
point 5 % ce taux est approuvé par le
tribunal
mais ce n'est pas la fin de l'histoire
à chaque année tout est à recommencer
malgré les tourments et le stress
nouvelles contestations en 2019
cette fois ils sont 46 résidents
l'ancien sous-ministre michel duchesneau
joint les rangs
vous subissez des représailles ou on est
horripilant l'extrême nos supports cpo
bien de ne pas devoir importer comme ça
on vous le fait sentir mesure peu de
temps après leur contestation
le prix des repas à la carte a grimpé de
20% à la résidence une aux abusif pour
michel duchesneau
il dépose une plainte au centre intégré
de santé et services sociaux de québec
après examens le commissaire admet que
la hausse est notable mais légal
la rpa a le droit d'augmenter les coûts
des services à la carte
à tout moment
la résidence ni exercer des représailles
et soutient que les augmentations de
loyer sont raisonnables en raison des
hausses du coût des salaires de la
nourriture et des fournitures donne les
promesses de services de l'infirmerie le
repas salle à manger d'animation et ce
spi le personnel concerné mon avis est
très correcte et c'est ce sur quoi en
fait
quand c'est sympa qu'un excès des
entourloupettes pas et nous a resserrés
souci un peu d'argent si un petit peu
dangereux bon ça n'a pas de bon sens où
il faut que ça y est rentable faut
pousser à aller le rendement sur capital
investi
mais arrêtez de charrier que nous
exploiter comme ça si hitler au retour
on va vous montrer qu'au moment où on en
a le plus besoin en perte d'autonomie
les services coûtent de plus en plus
cher au monde et en mangeant aux
seychelles
l'acceptation pièces par jour est de
monter
vous avez entendu monsieur petit gros
avant la pause qui parlait
d'entourloupettes il faut regarder le
modèle d'affaires de ces résidences
privées elles sont là pour faire du
profit
et quand c'est ça qui compte il ya rien
de gratuit des ménages est déjà bien
après que mon mari est décédé deux ans
après tu peux peut-être d'une grande
maison à tour chamakh j'ai appuyé et où
un bon show tous deux fini beaucoup pour
moi je vois pas de besoin d'autre chose
à 84 ans l'aurait dumais est en pleine
forme
merci mon dieu il est simple jusqu'à
présent seuls frais poule mais je sais
qu'un jour ça va venir mais j'aime dans
le moment je me dis gros épais que je
pars où il est tout de suite spice boy
[Musique]
madame du mais habite la résidence cité
jardin à gatineau
aujourd'hui elle prépare des cartes
qu'elle partagera avec des voisins je
reconnus est déjà bien comme madame du
mec fête l'aïd actuellement bf est
surtout les personnes seules les
personnes qui peuvent pas se déplacer
les personnes qui n'ont pas de famille
pour aider ses voisins elle fait des
ménages lavent leur ville organise des
activités mais surtout s occupe au
quotidien du bien-être de jeanine
langevin j'étais sa voisine et puis
comme des raisons je m'apercevais
qu'elle avait besoin de l'ied et puis ça
a commencé qu'après pu effacer la vague
puis moi comme je me sentais de la
bruche et ce dans le passage qu'un il a
pas juste à côté de moi et puis avait
beaucoup de difficulté à faire sont là
bas je savais plus bon sens pour un
total bien ça fait lourd j'ai pris en
charge
[Musique]
laurette a pris soin de sa voisine
pendant cinq ans malgré tout l'état de
madame l'angevin s'est détériorée quant
à leur entrée à leur entrée comme
autonome mais avec les années on a par
un peu à la 89e puis ses jambes pas pu
marcher
j'allais le maire terre
j'allais lui donner à des jeunes et papa
ensuite l ' on pouvait manger tout seul
s'habiller tout seul de la seule chose
c'est que elle avait besoin des beaux
sports sur jallet l'uimm et c'est beau
sport à tous les matins je les lui
enlever il soit les services de soutien
à domicile de ces essais sont offerts
aux résidants des rpa un employé vient
donc donné en vain une fois par semaine
à genève langevin mais il ne peut pas
répondre à tous ces besoins
que l'est celle ci ne pourra pas venir
lors d'un déjeuner puis l'ena dîner puis
le boire à ses besoins de classe journée
avec ces logements sont occupés
madame langevin pourrait aussi demander
de l'aide aux préposés de sa résidence
mais elle n'en a pas les moyens la
madame à la pomme beaucoup de sous le
charme est réveillé par la vache ces
deux pensions fait qu'elle demeurait
d'un studio pied d'amendé ah si quand
même lot selon ses revenus avec
monétairement va pas se permettre sur
l'eau c'était micouleau vous remettez
bossi le chef d'al monte et on mange en
eau
ces chefs faire c'est à ces pièces de
jour mais j'ai monté juste oublié de
maintenance de deux métiers
donc c'est ce que j'ai travaillé vingt
lots auprès des résidents faire toutes
sortes de choses j'ai gagné délégué
syndical à la csn
il représente les travailleurs des
quelques résidences privées pour aînés
syndiqués la problématique et quand la
perte d'autonomie s'annonce chaud arrive
c'est là où la facturation comment cela
pour les risques qu'est-ce qu'on facture
ben on facture un peu de tout comme
comme je les climatiseurs 4 l'été arrive
le change mais de l'installation des
thématise à retirer des climatiseurs
l'automne yonne multitude de de travaux
qui vont être chargés aux résidents puis
l'on parle pas des soins au niveau des
soins basse et une panoplie de de
service qui est facturé aux mots ou
allah ou à l'acte nous avons fait une
moyenne de certains frais à partir de
listes que nous avons pu
changer une ampoule 5 dollars un stand
climatiseurs 36 monter au repas
l'appartement 7 de la lettre et enlever
débat pour hypertension 24 dollars
gouttes pour les yeux 9 $ injections
d'insuline 9 dollars distribution de
médicaments 9 $ prise de la tension
artérielle 11 de la prise de la
température 11 dollars aide à
l'habillement 12 dollars aide pour un
bain 35 dollars faire marcher 15 minutes
vite dollars assistance à la toilette 8
dollars
je pense que lorsque les soins sont au
rendez vous ça coûte cher parce que
l'évaluation des besoins des résidents
dépôt standardisés et deuxièmement les
grilles tarifaires aussi ne sont pas
standardisés et il ya des résidences où
il y aura un abus un abus de financiers
parce que en charge extrêmement cher
lorsque des services sont nécessaires
c'est la même infirmier particules qui
est payé à même les buy ins tomasi dans
mon bail le salaire de l'infirmière legs
caméra xilai reçoit ou de la nuit
c'est dans mon prix dans mon bail que je
m'en serve que je pense au repos sauf
que je suis j'ai besoin d'eux ne peut
pas les toucher les pilules pour
distribuer trois fois par jour je
reconnais des dames qui entrent comme ça
gérard courtois savin casse par mois en
plus de leur bail en bref la présence
d'une infirmière est incluse au bail
mais pas ses soins
ou vraiment leur donner la bonne
information et des fois et 10 présence
d'infirmières sur place ou présence de
soins infirmiers
mais poser des questions est ce que
vraiment une infirmière ou une
infirmière auxiliaire sur place 24
heures 7 jours ça ça fait 7 jours
semaine pour toujours des fois et l'eau
le matin des fois il au juste les
premiers 10 des foyers l'homme et au
téléphone les résidents achète aussi une
plus grande sécurité un système d'appel
d'urgence qui promet que l'aide n'est
jamais loin
il est à peu près sept heures et demie
puis logis dieu oh mon dieu pourquoi
madame la jeunesse etc aurait plus eu
d'arrivée l'eau la camo monter à gauche
parce qu'elles étaient étendus à terre
plein de saint laver la plaie de st les
mets la main plein de sales étendue
journaux le jul il crie son nom
madame langevin vous êtes corée avec
madame l'ange bleu parce que ta mort
avec a dit oui ça fait longtemps jitsu
j'ai sonné avant de courir en gros quand
j'ai vu qu'elle n'a pas la cas de
malades sont venus depuis l'aube et on
appeler l'ambulance
voyant que l'infirmière n'arrive pas et
n'étant pas certaine que la sir est
fonctionne elle descend la course
chercher de l'aide
chat were nous assure que son système
d'appels à l'aide fonctionnait bien mais
ce n'est pas toujours le cas dans les
rpa
nous avons tenu 240 rapports
d'inspection fait dans des rpa entre
janvier et août 2019
on y apprend que 15% des rp a inspecté
avait un système d'appel d'urgence
défaillant encore plus inquiétant cette
compilation révèle que 49 % des rpa
avait des plans de sécurité incendie non
conformes
le décès de madame or les hôtes du cep
démontre que même dans une résidence
haut de gamme comme le lux gouverneur la
sécurité peut être défaillante
[Musique]
cette femme âgée de 93 ans a été
retrouvée morte le 20 janvier 2019 il
avait quitté son logement lorsque la
larme de feu est activé par erreur dans
la tour où elle habitait et s'est
retrouvé coincé à l'extérieur pendant
six heures dans une tempête de neige et
un froid mordant
des caméras sont les regarde pas ça sert
à rien il importe qui
on entend la larme mais si on entend la
dame ont l'art et elle me regarde pas
l'autre côté ce qu'on dit qu'on a défait
le démembrement pour le pape et ça
commence à faire beaucoup de problèmes
or destine accepteurs la famille duceppe
poursuit la résidence pour 1 1 million
250 mille dollars
alléguant de la négligence et des
lacunes dans le protocole de sécurité
incendie de ne pas avoir
à assumer ce qu'ils avançaient comme
publicité à savoir cet endroit est très
sécuritaire
les personnes qui sont ici par son aile
tout est là tout était en place de façon
évidente ça ça prend quelqu'un la
résidence réserve ses commentaires pour
le procès mais tient à préciser que la
sécurité et le bien-être de ses
résidents a toujours été et demeure à sa
priorité
heureusement l'histoire se termine bien
pour madame langevin qui vit aujourd'hui
dans un c est celle d où son ancienne
voisine lui rend visite
vous l'avez vu hein ça prend des sous
pour vivre en résidence privée
et là vous allez voir qu'il vaut mieux
aussi être en santé
notre enquête se poursuit après la pause
le préposé pas voir 50 personnes
administré un médicament lors du souper
les risques d'erreurs sont mous
quintuplé
beaucoup de gens font ce choix de
quitter leur maison et s'établir en
résidences privées en pensant au jour
ils seront plus capables de s'occuper
d'eux mêmes mais le personnel en
résidence
l'ipo toujours là dans leur présentation
en ligne des rpa offre des images
générées par ordinateur d'une clientèle
rêver de jeunes retraités fringant mais
dans les faits près de la moitié des
gens qui habitent dans une ère pea en 85
ans et plus 40 % des rpa se sont donc
adaptés au vieillissement de leur
clientèle en ajoutant des unités de
soins
les unités fermées pour des gens avec
des pertes cognitives et même des soins
palliatifs
on a des résidences privées où est ce
que aucun professionnel de santé
c'est à dire on a décidé que il y avait
des non professionnels qui sont des
préposés pour la plupart du temps et qui
donnent des soins mais des soins
infirmiers on ne compte que trois mille
infirmières et infirmières auxiliaires à
l'emploi dans les 1700 résidence
pour pallier cette pénurie le ministère
de la santé a amendé en 2003 le code des
professions pour donner aux préposés
plus de responsabilités c'est inquiétant
de savoir qu' il ya des gens avec peu de
formations qui peuvent administrer des
médicaments tels que du dilaudid de la
morphine de l'insuline qui laissait dit
qu'ils sont des médicaments aux risques
de préjudice
donc pour une clientèle aussi
de plus en plus en perte d'autonomie on
leur demande pas de connaître quels
ministres on leur demande d'administrer
des médicaments
l'ordre des infirmières auxiliaires lève
le drapeau rouge depuis cinq ans ils
demandent au gouvernement d' oublier les
rpa à maintenir du personnel infirmier
surtout les quarts de travail lorsqu'on
arrive dans un grand groupe donc
collectif ou est-ce que le préposé pas
voir 50 personnes administré un
médicament lors du souper des risques
d'erreurs son quintuplé exponentielle de
comex est arrivé l'erreur est humaine
mais il faut savoir aussi comment réagir
lorsqu'un une erreur de médicament non
seulement les préposés sont débordés
mais ils n'ont pas tout suivi une
formation de base
le préposé ah1n1 pourrez les suivre
cette formation donc de secourisme de
principe de déplacements sécuritaires de
bénéficiaires est inversé la réanimation
cardiorespiratoire
oui il ya une situation dangereuse parce
que en plus c'est que souvent le préposé
9 crois pas une minute entière
il va changer d'endroit et là il va
aller travailler ailleurs et
probablement que la formation ne la
suivra jamais la fédération des préposés
aux bénéficiaires déplore également le
manque de formation mais elle soutient
que la pénurie d'infirmières n'est pas
près de se résorber et qu'il est
illusoire d'espérer plus de personnel
infirmier dans les rpa
après une longue carrière comme
infirmières dans le réseau public
liette jalbert accepte un poste dans une
ère pea mais la première impression
était bonne parce que sinon je reprends
les les aménagements était beau les
chambres des grandes avec chacun salle
devrait priver pour chaque personne
j ai dû albert était alors directrice
des soins infirmiers dans une grande rpa
qu'elle préfère que nous ne nions pas
elle n'a pas tardé à déchanter
on travaille avec une philosophie de
soins mais des investisseurs ça
travaille pas avec une philosophie soit
sept travaillent avec une philosophie de
rentabilité c'est le coeur ya un décor
pense pas que ce soit rejoigne sommes
pour un ce décalage est parfois lourd de
conséquences pour eux ce pot répondent
aux besoins du passé à 6 même si en
europe on identifie les besoins du
patient c'est pas nécessaire contrôle on
n'est pas capable de trouver vraiment ce
qu'il faut pour répondre pour que ça
correspond alors à leur rentabilité
alors s'il ya des coupes sur les reports
coupe sur les soins en coupe sur les
bains en coupe sur les serviettes en
coupe sur le papier toilette en coupe
sur les cliniques sont en cours sur
beaucoup de choses sur les cauchemars
mais ce que vous direz que cette
rentabilité de ce côté mercantile ça se
faisait au détriment du bien-être des
gens ou c'est trop mais pas dans tous
les corps mais dans certains cas oui
pour les subventions seront versées ou
rpa aux résidences pour personnes âgées
aux ressources intermédiaires de type
familial dans notre jargon les airs il a
hérité f et au ch et celle des privés
afin que ces milieux d'hébergement soit
en mesure d'offrir les mêmes
bonifications à leur personne les deux
chercheuses louise boivin et anne-claude
questionne cette aide gouvernementale
elle termine une étude sur l'impact de
la course aux profits en hébergement
pour un nez mais là comme ils veulent
pas augmenter les salaires mais demande
à l'état des finances de financer les
augmentations de salaires donc c'est les
sons les fonds publics qui maintiennent
un modèle d'affaires qui garantissent
qui vont avoir un profit pour des grands
groupes
les fonds publics sont pas sensibles
destinées à ça les résidences privées
pour aînés ont-elles toutes besoin de
l'aide de l'état
on n'a aucune idée donc c'est très
difficile de savoir s'il pourrait se
permettre d'augmenter les salaires
et c'est possible qu'il soit incapable
réellement de le faire en maintenant une
marge bénéficiaire suffisante pour
survivre
et puis dans ce cas là si c'est le cas
ben ça veut dire que je tends modèle
d'affaires qui fonctionne pas
nous avons demandé aux propriétaires des
cinq grands gros d'ouvrir leurs livres
et de nous accorder une entrevue
ils ont tous refusé le groupe maurice
nous a répondu que ces profits ne
proviennent pas des services rendus à la
clientèle
il faut avoir des plans d'intervention
il faut être capable de savoir ce que
les services ont réellement été donnée
et à quel prix
et il a un moment donné au fait que les
résidences ouvrent leurs livres parce
que on peut pas demander les subventions
à l'état et à ne pas être transparent
par rapport à la gestion des finances
mais elles diront qu'elles sont des
entreprises privées alors pas de
subventions d'état
on peut pas avoir le beurre et l'argent
du beurre à l'exception du groupe savoie
qui est une entreprise familiale
la plupart des grands groupes de rpa
sont financés par des actionnaires des
fonds d'investissement privés des fonds
de retraite des propriétaires invoque
des ententes de confidentialité pour
taire le nom de leurs investisseurs des
investisseurs qui sont à la recherche de
bons placements
jean françois gibert ne pas accès aux
états financiers des grands joueurs mais
il a une bonne idée des rendements
annuels
laurent m'a courant donc les rendements
annuels l'on peut varier entre eux ça ne
vendais ça dépend des années bidet des
compagnies mais généralement ça va
varier entre 7 et 10%
il ya quelques uns qui dépasse un peu le
dise pour ça mais je vous dirais que ça
se situe pas mal dans cette
dans cette fourchette là un taux de
rendement annuel entre 7 et 10% pour la
plupart le groupe sélection retraite ci
a précisé que le sien plutôt de l'ordre
de 6% ses romans seront ils suffisants
pour satisfaire les investisseurs
les résidents risque utile d'en faire
les frais j'imagine que les pro bowl les
propriétaires vont essayer de doro aussi
leur lot leur loyer en conséquence
maintenant il reste à voir si la
réceptivité de la hausse de loyer par
les locataires doit être au rendez vous
pour faire passer la pilule d'une hausse
de loyer le regroupement québécois des
résidences pour aînés demande au
gouvernement de bonifier les crédits
d'impôt dont bénéficient les résidents
le gouvernement a accompli jusqu'à un
certain point parce qu'avec les crédits
d'impôt pour maintien domicile à 80 %
des gens qui réclament le crédit d'impôt
médecin domicile c'est des gens qui
vivent en résidence privée pourquoi
parce que les résidences à aider les
personnes à réclamer ce crédit d'impôt
l'eau et même les secondes dans certains
cas dans le coût du loyer alors il ya
une subvention déguisée de l'état dans
les résidences pour personnes âgées
nouveau cema non c'est non seulement les
salaires doivent être augmentés mais
pour julie saint germain il faudra
embaucher du personnel
tout dernièrement on ne
deux infirmières etc
deux jours pour 222 rythme avec en plus
la supervision des préposés qui
administre les médicaments c'est quand
même une lourde tâche là pour 222
résidents semi-autonome 200 résidents et
plus ces quatre personnes le seuil
minimal est de 4 personnes mais on
devrait parler plutôt d'un seuil optimal
ce milieu là il y en a pas de norme
quelle est la présence d'infirmières par
exemple quelle est l'évaluation qu'on
devrait faire des gens qui habitent dans
ces résidences la ja dans le réseau
public des outils standardisés qui
permettent d'évaluer les besoins des
personnes et de pouvoir faire un plan
d'intervention dans les résidences
privées c'est loin d'exister loin d'être
la norme c'est quelques résidences qui
ont dit au standard mais c'est pas le
lot de tout
au retour on vous parle de ces
résidences qui acceptent des patients
qui ont besoin de beaucoup trop de soins
pour leurs capacités
le personnel n'était pas formé ça
m'apparaît assez clair et avait pas de
sécurité
pour les proches des aînés qui vivent en
résidence c'est souvent une paix
d'esprit de penser que son parent est
bien en sécurité
mais quand il arrive à l'incident et que
c'est l'omerta sur les circonstances on
peut se poser de sérieuses questions sur
les comptes que ses résidents sont à
rendre la coronaire francine d'année à
enquêter sur les circonstances de - 25
décès dans des rpa en deux ans le décès
de germaine la belle l'a troublé pour
moi une personne âgée qui meurt c'est un
fait de la vie c'est un fait un dut
pourquoi est ce que cette dame là a
souffert ce nombre dans l'eau avant
d'être enfin soulagé c'est ce qui me
préoccupe et c'est ce qui me concernait
germaine label habitait un joli 4 et
nuit à la résidence château de l'est la
gatineau ses enfants lui rendre visite
plusieurs fois par semaine et constate
en 2011 que son état se dégrade
ma mère avait perdu commandite toute
orientation spatio temporelle c'est le
temps se repérer dans l'espace était
plus capable ça fait c'est l'eau qui ont
suggéré qu'elle n'osait plus de soins
appropriés au quatrième étage qui way
qui était assez simple en 2016 elle
déménage donc à l'unité de soins de la
résidence de l'île appartenant au même
propriétaire
elle allait avoir un meilleur suivi de
la part de l'infirmière c'était supposé
de ça ces médicaments elle et lui a
donné accès à ces médicaments et le mali
bon j'avais
je la surveille également rachel ses
déplacements ce suivi a un coût ici
comme dans tout les rpa à chaque tranche
d'une heure de soins on parle d'environ
1000 dans l'or
par mois n'ont qu'une personne qui a
besoin de deux heures soins par jour
à
va payer 2000 $ de plus par mois donc 1
4000 dollar 3500 4000 $ 4500 $ par mois
germaine la belle avait besoin des deux
pour manger se vêtir et se lever le
personnel n'était pas fort mais ça me
paraît assez clair il y avait pas de
sécurité puis je pense qu'elle va pas
suffisamment de personnel de faire
manger tous ces gens qui étaient
incapables de manger eux-mêmes faisait
exprès pour y aller à l'heure des repas
donc on la faisait mangent les piles au
cas où la faisait manger à manger bien
ip abuser puis le côté paulo belo il
nous disait on leur demandait au oui à
le bien manger le bien manger mais on
voit bien que non il est exposé aussi
lui couper sa nourriture
on arrivait des fouaces te couper la
viande et en tient comme soudain
recommencé leurs soupçons ont été
confirmés lorsque leur mère était amené
à l'urgence en mars 2018
elle est dans un état de dénutrition et
de déshydratation avancé
pourquoi qu'ont eu les c alice cette
situation là et que ç'a pris l'hôpital
pour intervenir mais quel rapport avez
eu à ça j'en ai pas de famille pas de
réponse l'eau j'en ai pas de réponse
la résidence de lille nous a répondu
qu'il arrive que des patients refusent
de manger
est ce que vous pensez qu'on prenait 1
de la faire manger une bouchée par ci
par logement c'est ce qui faisait juste
deux jours remarqué qu'ils se
promenaient l'opium adam manger plus lui
donner une bouchée passer à l'autre
patiente je sais pas combien de fois il
faisait le tour
de retour à sa résidence son état
s'aggrave en juillet germaine la belle
fait une chute le matin elle est bien
fait sa toilette avec les préposés saab
et les vues de et les vues et les deux
bouts une demi heure trois quarts
d'heure après sa dame de compagnie
arrive tout d'un coup elle est super
souffrent bonjour seul téléphone tout
simplement le matin assez tôt c'était de
sa dame de compagnie qui venait pour lui
donner un bain justement philo ma mère
était couché pas semblé vraiment
souffrante puis avec des capes trouvait
pas bouger les postures pouvait pas se
lever
à 3 heures un préposé la voie parce
qu'il soit dit ouais madame label vo pro
bien il va l'avoir qui dit avons
vraiment pro bien je pense qu'il faut
qu'on appelle une ambulance
l'ambulance n'est appelé jusqu'à
seulement à 6 heures et quelques temps 6
heures et 7 trois heures plus tard à
l'urgence on nous a dit que ma mère moi
je savais proches le site est tellement
stupéfaite elle avait le bassin fracturé
germaine abel moeurs huit jours plus
tard en état de dénutrition sévère et
déshydratés il a également une plaie de
pression cox est ce une fracture du ram
ont pu bien la coroner ouvre une enquête
parce qu'elle trouve les circonstances
suspectes
elle veut savoir ce qui est arrivé
comment madame la baisse est-elle
blessés il n'y a aucun rapport
d'accident pas de note au dossier la
coronaire fait face à un mur de silence
des chutes un résidence pour personnes
âgées dans les domiciles dans les c s
est soldée dans les hôpitaux
il y en a tous les jours ça fait parti
d'un fait de la vie alors pourquoi
cacher un événement qui que je
qualifierais de presque banal passé
pogba nasa la cause d'un décès mais un
événement qui arrive quand ni où ni le
désir d'accéder nita des lieux personnes
au nom de votre mère ne pas tomber
bon il ya quatre médecins qui nous ont
dit qu'elle s'est fracturé le bassin
qu'elle ne pouvait pas se relever seul à
appeler quelqu'un pour le relevé la tête
dans son lit
mais c'est quand la foux dans son lit en
plus mon prévient personne pendant les
cieux elle n'avait pas souffrir comme ça
c'est sûr que notre mère soit morte
autre façon mais la peyrade le fait
qu'elle soit tombée
puis je prendre soin comme jeter
n'importe quoi locaux dans son luxe et
finit cependant pas de coca et
enregistre des inspections mai et aucune
obligation de divulgation à
l'établissement qui fait la
certification qui laissait sous le siège
donc l'eau et les instances ne sont pas
comptabilisés
même les enquêteurs de police qui ont
assisté la coronaire dans son enquête
n'ont pas réussi à délier les langues
au delà de ce mutisme la coronaire
s'interroge sur les qualifications du
personnel dans les résidences
en général les patients ont besoin et
les préposés aux bénéficiaires sont
capables de donner des bains d'habiller
sont capables de nourrir sont capables
de faire ses besoins physiques lot de
base mais ils ne sont pas capables de
donner des soins de desbin là je vais
faire des pansements
je vais désinfecter les plaies peuvent
pas ça prend un infirmier ère
auxiliaires ou infirmières on leur
demande de faire des soins infirmiers
sont pas à l'aise je devrais administrés
l'insuline faire une injection
d'insuline pour tout le monde qui est à
l'aise de faire ça et d'autres soins
plus invasives dans des catégories
musicales comme je vous ai parlé ou
d'administrer des médicaments des
narcotiques et ils voient le danger
eux-mêmes non mais ils vont conduire ils
vont quitter ils vont aller travailler
au public ou est-ce que c'est respecter
en ch et celle des vous verrez pas de
préposés aux bénéficiaires soit faire
des soins invasifs où elle ministres et
des médicaments
ça ne fait pas partie de leur champ
d'exercice
jean françois gilbert concède que
certaines rpa acceptent des cas trop
lourd ce que j'ai à l'esprit qui qui
accepte ce genre de client alors un
obstacle le fait qu'ils n'ont pas
nécessairement toute l'expertisé à
l'intérieur pour les accepter
généralement ce sont des résidences qui
sont affectés par un niveau
d'inoccupation élevé dans leur résidence
il accepte dans ce temps là des des
clients un peu plus l'eau à la résidence
de l'île où le g madame label l'unité de
soins compte 130 chambres réparties sur
deux étages dont 54 patients en attente
d'une place en chsct qui ont besoin de
plusieurs heures de soins par jour
mathématiquement parlant c'est
impossible mais ça pour capable de
remplir ses obligations non son coca par
son papa et c'est mathématiquement c'est
impossible à sa défense le groupe cat à
sa propriétaire de la résidence de l'île
soutient qu'il n'est pas un centre
hospitalier et que le sis de l'outaouais
lui confier des cas trop lourd pour ses
capacités
kata ça n'a pas voulu nous accorder une
entrevue
mais il affirme que la situation s'est
améliorée depuis la résidence de lille a
reçu 17 avis de non-conformité lors de
l'inspection de 2019 ont tort de ne pas
avoir respecté le seuil minimal de
quatre préposés au quatrième étage là où
se trouvait madame label
sur ce point kata ça ne nous a pas
fourni d'explications
cette résidence appartient à samir
choueiry le même propriétaire que la
résidence est rond le ch et s'était
rendu tristement célèbre par sa
négligence à protéger les patients de
l'aco vide
[Musique]
selon un sondage de la firme léger de
94 % des résidents de rpa sont
satisfaits je pense que la génération
inverse génération des bébé-boumeurs
qu'on appelle la génération silencieuse
et que charlie par ce genre de modèle là
ils ont vécu à une époque où c'était
difficile et là ils ont l'impression que
une fois qu'ils sont rendus dans le
grand âge belote
ils peuvent profiter plus volontiers
d'un milieu qui leur apporte sécurité et
qu'ils leur apportent activités et c'est
dans cette génération là je pense à s a
été séduit par ce chant des sirènes
je suis pas sûr que les bébé-boumeurs
qui suivent après quoi être aussi
séduits par ce modèle doit je pense que
les bb boomers vont vouloir continuer à
vivre chez eux de façon indépendante de
façon mieux intégrés dans la société
pour réjean hébert le prix à payer pour
que des années vivent comme à l'hôtel
est très cher payé
sans compter leur héritage qui part en
fumée qui ne sera pas transféré aux
enfants au delà du choix qu'ils font il
est important pour lui de s'assurer
maintenant que leurs droits soient
respectés que ces milieux de vie soit
mieux encadré même si la génération
silencieuse comme on l'appelle l'est de
moins en moins
pour l'année 2018 2019 les commissaire
aux plaintes du québec ont reçu 850
plaintes de résidants de rpa et de leurs
familles
un phénomène qui étaient à la hausse
selon des commissaires
michel che nous signe sa deuxième lettre
de doléances à la commissaire aux
plaintes de résidants de l'opéra ce cas
sonne encore sur lavinia rab liquide il
a dit considérer comme une marchandise
qui doit générer un maximum de profit
[Musique]
oui
j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
je
[Musique]